doctors stretched to the limit patients
gasping for air keep arriving but there
aren't enough beds most of the really
sick here in Bergamo are elderly but
medics warn young people they too are
vulnerable fifty percent of our patients
in the ICU which are the most severe
patients fifty percent of our patients
are over 65 years old but that means
that the other 50% is younger than 65
and we have patients
20 years old 30 years old what if you
italy is racing to get temporary
hospital was up and running this one has
been opened by a US charity in the
northern city of cremona we came here
because our fellow brothers and sisters
our Italian brothers and sisters are
hurting the horrifying situation in the
north is now being replicated in the
South here in Naples the streets are
empty but the hospitals are starting to
fill up the figures basically reflected
that of Lombardi two weeks ago manaphy
resident scrub all surfaces they think
might be susceptible to contamination
but no matter how much they clean
nothing can remove the fear of infection
correspondent Seema Gupta joins us from
Rome Seema the death toll in Italy saw
this unprecedented leap on Friday do
experts understand why well Rebecca
there are hypotheses and the first one
the most the one that's being repeated
often by the officials is simply because
Italy has a significant number of
elderly it's the second oldest
population in the world
a quarter of the population is over the
age of 65 and so if you are older if you
have underlying health conditions such
as diabetes or hypertension or heart
disease you soak up more easily to this
infection unfortunately basically it
targets it's the more fragile members of
society and that's why we're seeing
these high numbers second possible
reason is the fact that the health care
system is so under strain right now I
mean there were cuts in the system in
the past and on top of that of course
we've seen doctors some eight percent of
doctors that are included in the list of
those infected and the third possible
reason is that maybe this lockdown in
particular Lombardi could have been done
earlier but for now though people are
just focusing on treating those who need
the help
yeah well you mentioned the elderly
population but as we heard in the police
paying the piece rather half of the
patients are younger than 65 young
people taking precaution seriously well
that's the whole point I mean what the
authorities are saying is that you can
be young you can have the infection and
it will not present any symptoms in fact
you may just have a mild cold if
anything or a few aches and pains
because you're younger that's it though
again it comes back to the point if you
are a fragile if you have some fragile
issues basically if you have underlying
health conditions even though you're
younger it could have a dramatic impact
so that's why you're also seeing some
younger patients in the intensive care
units and that's why the authorities are
stressing that everyone has to do their
part in order to limit the spread so
even if you're younger you need to help
such that the older members of society
don't get the infection and then
further measures are being taken in
Italy to curb the spread well what we do
know now is that the next week or so is
a crucial one and that's because it
leads nowhere near its peak in terms of
the number of infections and therefore
the authorities have clamped down even
further right now no public parks are
open as they are encouraging you to
conduct any sporting activity any
exercise at home or close to home food
stores close to train stations will all
be shut and no one is allowed to move to
their second homes if you like each
region is also putting in place specific
measures here in Rome for example there
will be more controls on the streets as
well as road blocks to ensure that
people are not moving about without any
valid reason up north in the Lombardy
region the president of the region asked
for military on the streets he got 114
personnel in the city of Milan he says
that's not enough he needs more measures
put in place to prevent people from
going outside and in veneto they're
saying you can't even walk your dog
beyond 200 meters from your residence so
really all these measures to ensure that
people stay at home because as I
mentioned this next week or so is
crucial as we hope Italy heads towards
its peak it all depends on the
projections and the trends that the
scientists are looking at the head of
the Civil Protection Services say it
could be anything between next week or
the week after same a Gupta reporting
for us from Rome thank you